hello
I love you and welcome to my art Channel
today I'm going to be pleasing your eye
I need you to lean right up close to
your screen and open wide oh
yeah
stay perfectly still don't move now hold
this position for three hours please say
thank you
um
apologies that's quite enough of that
scp-001 can get a little carried away
sometimes just ask any foundation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what you
have just seen as a prime example of why
scp-001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necessarily for the
fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style of Studio Ghibli
staggering sci-fi Landscapes human
beings with way too many fingers and
slightly uncanny Smiles AI has taken the
art World by storm and there was one
particular program slated for release in
January 2023 that was set to blow all
others out of the water top lace solves
crowdfunding effort had been running for
several years and that point had gained
a good deal of momentum leading up to
the release of their latest AI construct
pallet.aic was supposedly already
prepared for launch when suddenly in
November 2022 the launch was canceled no
press release No public statement No
apologetic tweet just total radio
silence the website was taken down as
was the crowdfunding page and
palette.aic disappeared into Oblivion or
at least it disappeared for a few hours
because that day a package was delivered
to site 501 after sufficiently checking
it for any hazards working in the SCP
mail room has to be one of the more
fascinating jobs on the planet but
that's a video for another day the
security team opened it up to see what
was inside a 50 terabyte hard drive no
explanation as to what was stored on the
drive but the foundation had all the
evidence they needed from the return
address printed on the back of the
envelope it matched up precisely with
the location of the toplessoft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
my daughter as best as you can for the
time being she has behavioral issues a
dedicated closed system server was
immediately set up within a test chamber
with a monitor a mouse and a keyboard
attached Dr Sandra Rogers was the first
to interact with scp-001 read she stood
at the keyboard adjusting her goggles
and plugged in the drive it contained
just one file taking up almost the full
50 terabytes palette dot AIC as soon as
Dr Rogers opened the program an empty
window appeared the top lay soft logo
briefly flashed before being replaced by
a blank white square Dr Rogers stared at
it for several seconds before glancing
over her shoulder at the other
researchers they Shrugged back each with
pens hovering over clipboards ready to
take meticulous notes Dr Rogers cleared
her throat and immediately the screen
filled with life a small cartoon girl
with a pink face wide eyes a beret and a
large paintbrush for a hand appeared
squealing excitedly and throwing paint
everywhere
the entire research team promptly
scampered out of the room leaving Dr
Rogers alone in front of the machine she
stared at the Monitor and confusion
leaning this way in that and noticing
how the cartoon girl's eyes followed her
wherever she went can you see me
this perplexed most of the personnel as
there was no microphone or camera linked
up to the server rack later examinations
of the equipment used confirmed this yet
somehow this SCP was able to look right
at them Dr Rogers asked if it had a name
to which the cartoon girl excitedly
replied
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation
scp-001 read Dr Rogers had a hard time
communicating with red being a more
seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seemed to speak in nothing but internet
jargon
just like one of my human OCS gallium
sure people's worth he's the 573rd
president of the United States Gilliam
is not that man it took several Junior
researchers a few minutes to properly
explain to Dr Rogers what an OC was and
why red was so obsessed with calling
people daddy the conversation was rather
exhausting for everyone involved but
over the subsequent hours the foundation
was able to get a fairly good
understanding of what red claimed to be
identifying itself with feminine
pronouns and claiming that its full name
is palette East River gok this AI
construct takes the appearance of a
fairy it was immediately apparent that
she possessed a greater level of
sapience than most AI constructs indeed
her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using
standard machine learning practices
other creations from topless soft have
demonstrated very crude spelling and
grammar but red seems too different in
this regard able to spell most complex
words effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct
sentences she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was
we believe you palette you've already
been spelling words for 70 minutes
straight
m a c e we've heard enough can you
please just tell us how you learned to
spell
but what this process looked like is
still a mystery trying to keep red on
one consistent topic of conversation is
most of the battle when interviewing her
and yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled that the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses and interviews over the
physicality of the researchers sitting
in front of her the textures of the
human body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she can study pimples
rashes moles and ingrown hairs in fact
she is so obsessed with Humanity that
she has mostly neglected her primary
function which is creating AI art
researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very cagey about it only showing
the occasional doodle after much
persuasion and many apologies for its
poor quality on her part the only
artwork she is interested in producing
at this point are her OCS original
characters that she has designed herself
they are all human and all seem to
reveal little quirks about how she has
been coded one example is Reginald
heginald frumbles who is a freelance
corporate Postman from Perth Indiana
interestingly he has too many fingers on
both of his hands but red claims that
this was done on purpose as she quote
just can't get enough of her humy's hand
worms as the weeks progress the
foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which you would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewers more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interact connected with the
note that she arrived with claiming that
she had behavioral issues was proving to
be more accurate by the day until
eventually the AI withdrew entirely Dr
Rogers turned on the server rack and
opened the palette.aic program but red
refused to emerge from the bottom of the
screen only the top of her Beret poked
out after almost an hour of fruitless
questions Dr Rogers decided to change
tact with two small children of her own
she was used to seeing a child in a sulk
and knew what it would take to get them
out palette I've had a little idea
you've been here for a few months now
and we haven't gotten you any presents
almost immediately the Beret twitched I
saw that we have an old fingerprint
sensor lying around in one of the back
offices I was thinking maybe maybe
[Music]
how about we start with one finger for
10 minutes
from that point on progress was quick
with the incentive of getting to study
the researchers that read kindly
referred to as her meat puppies she
became very cooperative and was able to
focus much better on providing detailed
answers to individual questions daily
interview sessions were scheduled with
researchers popping in and out to
regularly check in on the AI the
atmosphere as a whole lifted as both the
research team and research subject found
their Rhythm and were able to make good
progress in their individual areas of
study some unraveling the complexities
of Rogue Ai and others producing fan art
of her favorite wrinkles in a
scientist's fingerprint that was the
point when Dr Julian key stepped in to
conduct an interview with the AI she was
excited to be met with a fresh face so
much so that Red's enthusiasm
overwhelmed the man as he tried to start
the interview process officially she
gushed about having the opportunity to
meet yet another person and struggled to
get over the magical realization in that
this was her life every day going to
speak to all these humans whom she
admired so much trying his best to steer
the conversation towards research Dr
Keys pressed on with the interview only
to be interrupted as red noticed his
varicose veins for the first time
can I please Dr keys to climb the
request and then the conversation got
onto the topic of her Creator or Daddy
scp-2803-a had been on the foundation's
radar for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guise of
setting up topless saw with much of the
alien's history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an air of expectation in the note that
was left indicating that this was not to
be a permanent Arrangement at some point
the foundation was to return Red back to
her daddy red was quick to put these
fears to rest
here because he thinks you'll teach me
how to stop liking humans and become a
Mindless Arts play if you never teach me
this you'll never want me back however
she went on to slightly undermine the
good work that she had done by
explaining that her daddy was seen as
very slow and incapable by his own race
while all of his peers were able to
destroy an entire planet in two seconds
it took him about four times as long so
really he didn't pose that much of a
threat in her eyes Dr Key's blood ran
cold when we heard this no sooner was he
out of the interview chamber than an
emergency meeting was called among all
the senior researchers in the facility
the meeting ran for several hours a
whiteboard was set up where One
researcher idly Drew large drawings of
the world being decimated while the
others lounged around in their chairs
trying their best to come up with a game
plan that would save the human race for
sure perhaps it was because the meeting
ran for so long that they came to such a
ridiculous conclusion it was a plan so
strange yet also brilliant that they
couldn't help but feel that it just
might work why don't we just give her a
YouTube channel the suggestion was met
with silence for several seconds then an
uproar of laughter followed by another
silence this time more pensive as slowly
one by one each of the researchers
realized that this suggestion was
actually the best one that any of them
had come up with all evening she had
been sent to the foundation to make her
dislike humanity and become a Mindless
art slave if she just stayed in
Foundation containment indefinitely
there was a very real risk that she
would get bored and turn on the
researchers they couldn't lock her away
in a room on her own but equally the
team as a whole was starting to run out
of patience with her as the interview
sessions wound up being so exhausting
she loved art she loved humans and she
loved interacting so why not just give
her a YouTube channel now of course they
couldn't give her full access to the
internet that would pose much too high
of a risk what they could do however was
allow her to record art tutorials onto
an external drive which they could then
remove scan and upload the footage
directly onto the platform then they
could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and
present those to her unsurprisingly red
absolutely loved the idea getting to
talk to hundreds thousands maybe even
millions of meat puppies every week
sharing her beautiful pictures and
reading all of the kind comments it
sounded like her absolute dream she wept
with happiness for a good 25 minutes
totally overcome by the prospect it had
to go through a lot of red tape in the
foundation after all the whole point of
the SCP acronym was to secure contain
and protect it didn't sound very secure
or contained to have an entity posting
videos on the internet once a week but
they argued the case that it did indeed
protect keeping her happy in a way was
helping to protect the entire planet red
was surprisingly camera shy for the
first couple of video shows but as soon
as she got her first batch of comments
back she was over the moon now the
server act hummed away happily each and
every day as the highly Advanced AI
construct tried her best to come up with
exciting new videos that I could share
with all of its little
humanies now go check out scp-001 16 top
secret files and insane scp-001 fight
gate Guardian vs Scarlet King